you've spoken with
eric weinstein your brother on his
podcast the portal
about the ideas that eventually led to
the paper you published
titled the reserved capacity hypothesis
i think first can you
explain this paper and the ideas that
led up to it
sure easier to explain the conclusion of
the paper
there's a question about why a creature
that
can replace its cells with new cells
grows
feeble and inefficient with age we call
that process which
is otherwise called aging we call it
senescence
and senescence in this paper
it is hypothesized is the unavoidable
downside
of a cancer prevention
feature of our bodies
that each cell has a limit on the number
of times it can divide
there are a few cells in the body that
are exceptional but most of our cells
can only divide a limited number of
times that's called the hayflick limit
and the hayflick limit uh reduces the
ability of the organism to replace
tissues it therefore
results in a failure over time of
maintenance and repair
and that explains why we we become
decrepit as we grow old
the question was why would that be
especially in light of the fact that the
mechanism
that seems to limit the ability of cells
to reproduce
is something called a telomere telomere
is a
it's a not a gene but it's a dna
sequence at the ends of our chromosomes
that is just simply repetitive and the
number of repeats
functions like a counter so there's a
number of repeats that you have
uh after development is finished and
then each time the cell divides a little
bit of telomere is lost
and at the point that the telomere
becomes critically short the cell
stops dividing even though it still has
the capacity to do so
stops dividing and it starts
transcribing different genes than it did
when it had
more telomere so what my work did
was it looked at the fact that the
telomeric shortening was being studied
by two different groups
it was being studied by people who were
interested
in counteracting the aging process and
it was being
studied in exactly the opposite fashion
by people who were interested
in tumerogenesis and cancer the thought
being
because it was true that when one looked
into tumors they always had
telomerase active that's the enzyme that
lengthens our telomeres
so those folks were interested in
uh bringing about a halt to the
lengthening of telomeres in order to
counteract cancer
and the folks who were studying the
senescence process
were interested in lengthening telomeres
in order to generate greater
repair capacity and my point was
evolutionarily speaking
this looks like a plyotropic
effect that the
genes which create the tendency of
the cells to be limited in their
capacity to replace themselves
are providing a benefit in youth which
is that we are
largely free of tumors and cancer at the
inevitable late life cost that we
grow feeble and inefficient and
eventually die and that
matches a very old hypothesis in
evolutionary theory
by somebody i was fortunate enough to
know george williams one of the great
20th century evolutionists
who argued that senescence would have to
be caused
by plyotropic genes that cause early
life benefits
at unavoidable late life costs and
although this
isn't the exact nature of the system he
predicted it matches
what he was expecting in many regards uh
to a shocking degree
that said the the the focus of the paper
is about
the well let me just read the abstract
we observed that captive rodent breeding
protocols designed this is the end of
the abstract
we observed that captive rodent breeding
protocols designed to increase
reproductive output
simultaneously exert strong selection
against reproductive senescence
and virtually eliminate selection that
would otherwise favor
tumor suppression this appears to have
greatly elongated the telomeres of
laboratory mice
with their telomeric fail-safe
effectively disabled these animals are
unreliable models of normal senescence
and tumor formation
so basically using these mice is not
going to lead to the right kinds of
conclusions
safety tests employing these animals
likely overestimate cancer risks
and underestimate tissue damage and
consequent
accelerated senescence so
i think especially with your discussion
with eric
the conclusion of this paper has to do
with the fact that
like we shouldn't be using these mice to
test the safety or to make conclusions
about
uh uh cancer or senescence
is that the basic takeaway like
basically saying that the length of
these telomeres is an important variable
to consider
well let's put it this way i think there
was a reason
that the world of scientists who was
working on telomeres did not spl
did not spot the plyotropic relationship
that uh was the
key argument in my paper
the reason they didn't spot it was that
there was a result that everybody knew
which seemed inconsistent the result was
that mice have very long telomeres but
they do not have
very long lives now we can talk about
what the actual meaning of
don't have very long lives is but in the
end
i was confronted with a hypothesis that
would explain a great many features of
the way mammals and indeed
vertebrates age but it was inconsistent
with one result and at first i thought
maybe there's something wrong with the
result maybe this is one of these cases
where the result was
achieved once through some bad protocol
and everybody else was repeating it
didn't turn out to be the case many
laboratories had established that mice
had ultra-long telomeres
and so i began to wonder whether or not
there was something
about the breeding protocols
that generated these mice and what that
would predict
is that the mice that have long
telomeres would be laboratory mice
and that wild mice would not and carol
grider
who agreed to collaborate with me tested
that hypothesis and showed that it was
indeed true
that while derived mice or at least mice
that had been in
captivity for a much shorter period of
time did not have ultra-long telomeres
now what this implied though as you read
is that our breeding protocols generate
lengthening of telomeres and the
implication of that is that the animals
that have these very long telomeres will
be
hyperprone to create tumors they will be
extremely resistant to toxins
because they have effectively an
infinite capacity to replace any damaged
tissue
and so ironically if you give one of
these ultra-long telomere
lab mice a toxin if the toxin doesn't
outright kill it it may actually
increase its lifespan because it
functions as a kind of chemotherapy
so the reason the chemotherapy works is
that dividing cells are more vulnerable
than cells that are not dividing
and so if this mouse has effectively had
its cancer protection turned off
and it has cells dividing too rapidly
and you gave it a toxin
you will slow down its tumors faster
than you harm its other tissues
and so you'll get a paradoxical result
that actually some drug that's toxic
seems to benefit the mouse now i don't
think that that was understood
before i publish my paper now i'm pretty
sure it has to be
and the problem is that this actually is
a system
that serves pharmaceutical companies
that have the difficult job
of bringing compounds to market many of
which
will be toxic maybe all of them will be
toxic
and these mice predispose our system to
declare these toxic compounds
safe and in fact i believe we've seen
the errors that result from using these
mice a number of times
most famously with vioxx which turned
out to do conspicuous
heart damage why do you think this paper
on this idea has not gotten significant
traction
well my collaborator carol grider said
something to me
that rings in my ears to this day
she initially after she showed that
laboratory mice have anomalously long
telomeres and that wild mice don't have
long telomeres
i asked her where she was going to
publish that result so that i could cite
it in my paper
and she said that she was going to keep
the result in-house
rather than publish it and at the time
i was a young graduate student i didn't
really
understand what she was saying but in
some sense
the knowledge that a model organism is
broken in a way that
creates the likelihood that certain
results will be reliably generatable
you can publish a paper and make a big
splash with such a thing
or you can exploit the fact that you
know how those models will misbehave
and other people don't so there's a
question
if somebody is motivated cynically
and what they want to do is appear to
have deeper insight into biology because
they predict things better than others
do
knowing where the flaw is so that your
predictions come out true
is advantageous at the same time
i can't help but imagine that the
pharmaceutical industry when it figured
out that the mice were predisposed
to suggest that drugs were safe
didn't leap to fix the problem because
in some sense
it was the perfect cover for the
difficult job of
bringing drugs to market and then
discovering their actual toxicity
profile
right this made things look safer than
they were and i believe a lot of profits
have likely been generated downstream
so to kind of play devil's advocate it's
also possible
that this particular the length of the
telomeres is not a strong variable for
the conclusions
for for the drug development and for the
conclusions that carol and others
have been studying is that is that is it
possible for that to be the case
that this like so one reason she and
others could be ignoring this
is because it's not a strong variable
well i don't believe so and in fact at
the point that i
went to publish my paper carol published
her result
um she did so in a way that did not make
a huge splash
did she like whoa i apologize if i don't
know
how what was the emphasis
of her publication of that paper
was it purely just kind of showing data
or is there more
because in your paper there's a kind of
more of a philosophical statement as
well
well my paper was motivated by interest
in the evolutionary dynamics around
senescence i wasn't
um you know pursuing grants or anything
like that i was just working on a puzzle
i thought was interesting
um carol has of course gone on to win a
nobel prize
for her co-discovery with elizabeth
grider
of telomerase the enzyme that lengthens
telomeres
but anyway she's a heavy hitter in the
academic world
i don't know exactly what her purpose
was i do know that she told me she
wasn't planning to publish and i do know
that i discovered that she was in the
process of publishing
very late and when i asked her to send
me the paper
to see whether or not she had uh put
evidence in it that the hypothesis had
come from me
she grudgingly sent it to me and my name
was nowhere mentioned and she has
she broke contact at that point um
what it is that motivated her i don't
know but i don't think it can possibly
be that this result is unimportant
the fact is the reason i called her in
the first place
and established contact that generated
our collaboration
was that she was a leading light in the
field of telomeric studies
and um because of that this
question about whether the model
organisms are distorting
the uh the understanding of the
functioning of telomeres is
it's central do you feel like you you've
been
as a young graduate student do you think
carol or do you think the scientific
community broadly screwed you over
in some way you know i don't think of it
in those terms probably partly because
it's not productive but you know i have
a
a complex relationship with this story
right on the one hand i'm livid with
carol grider for what she did
right she absolutely pretended that i
didn't exist in this story
and i don't think i was a threat to her
my interest was as an evolutionary
biologist
i had made an evolutionary contribution
she had tested a hypothesis and frankly
i think it would have been better for
her
if she had acknowledged what i had done
i think it would have enhanced
her work um and you know i was
let's put it this way when i watched her
nobel lecture and i should say there's
been a lot of confusion about this nobel
stuff i've never said that i should have
gotten
a nobel prize people have misportrayed
that
um my in listening to her
lecture i had one of the most bizarre
emotional experiences
of my life because she presented the
work
that resulted from my hypothesis she
presented it
as she had in her paper with no
acknowledgment of where it had come
from and she had uh in fact portrayed
the distortion of the telomeres as if it
were a lucky
fact because it allowed testing
hypotheses that would otherwise not be
testable you have to understand as
a young scientist to watch
work that you have done presented
in what's surely the most important
lecture of her
career right it's thrilling
it was thrilling to see you know her
her figures projected on the screen
there right to have been
part of work that was important enough
for that felt great and of course to be
erased from the story felt absolutely
terrible
um so anyway that's sort of where i am
with it my sense is
i what i'm really troubled by in this
story
is the fact that
as far as i know the flaw with the mice
has not been addressed
and actually eric did some looking into
this he tried to establish
by calling the jacks lab and trying to
ascertain
what had happened with the colonies
whether any change in protocol had
occurred
and he couldn't get anywhere there was
seemingly no awareness that it was even
an issue
so i'm very troubled by the fact that as
a father for example
i'm in no position to protect my family
from the hazard that i believe
lurks in our medicine cabinets right i'm
even though i'm aware of where the
hazard comes from
it doesn't tell me anything useful about
which of these drugs will turn out to do
damage if that is ultimately tested
and that's a very frustrating position
to be in
on the other hand you know there's a
part of me that's even still grateful to
carol
for taking my call she didn't have to
take my call and talk to some young
graduate student who had some
evolutionary idea that wasn't
you know in her wheelhouse specifically
and yet she did and you know for a while
she was a good collaborator so
well can i i have to proceed carefully
here because
it's it's a complicated topic um
so she took the call
and you kind of you're kind of saying
that she basically
erased credit you know pretending you
didn't exist in some kind of
in a certain sense
let me phrase it this way i've um as a
as a research scientist at mit i've had
and
especially just part of
a large set of collaborations i've had a
lot of students come to me
and talk to me about ideas perhaps less
interesting than what we're discussing
here
in the space of ai that i've been
thinking about anyway
in general with everything i'm doing
with robotics
people uh will have told me
a bunch of ideas that i'm already
thinking about the point is
taking that idea see this is different
because
the idea has more power in the space
that we're talking about here in
robotics is like your idea means
until you build it like so the
engineering world is a little different
but it there's a kind of sense that i
probably forgot
a lot of brilliant ideas have been told
to me
do you think she pretended you don't
exist
do you think she was so busy that she
kind of
forgot you know that she has like the
stream of brilliant people around her
that
there's a bunch of ideas that are
swimming in the air
and you just kind of forget people that
are a little bit on the periphery
on the idea generation like or is it
some mix of both
uh it's not a mix of both um i know that
because
we corresponded she put a graduate
student on this work
he emailed me excitedly when the results
came in so there was no ambiguity
about what had happened what's more when
i went to publish my work i actually
sent it to carol in order
to get her feedback because i wanted to
be a good collaborator to her
and she absolutely panned it made
many critiques that were not valid but
it was clear at that point that she
became an
antagonist and
none of this adds up she couldn't
possibly have forgotten the conversation
um i believe i even sent her tissues at
some point
in in part not related to this project
but as a favor she was doing another
project that involved telomeres and she
needed
samples that i could get a hold of
because of the museum of zoology that i
was in
so this was not a one-off conversation i
certainly know that those sorts of
things can happen but that's not what
happened here
this was a relationship that existed
and then was suddenly cut short at the
point that she
published her paper by surprise without
saying where the hypothesis had come
from
and uh began to be a
opposing force to my work is there
there's a bunch of trajectories you
could have taken through life
do you think about the trajectory of
being
um a researcher of then going to
to war in the space of ideas of
publishing further papers along this
line
i mean that's often the dynamic of
that fascinating space is you have a
junior researcher with brilliant ideas
and a senior researcher that
that starts out as a mentor that becomes
a competitor i mean that that happens
but then the way to uh
it's an almost an opportunity to shine
is to publish a bunch more papers in
this
place like to tear it apart to dig into
like really uh make it a war of ideas
did you consider that
possible trajectory i did a couple
things to say about it
one this work was not central for me
i took a year on the telomere project
because
something fascinating occurred to me and
i pursued it and the more i pursued it
the clearer it was there was something
there
but it wasn't the focus of my graduate
work and
i didn't want to become a telomere
researcher what i want to do
is to be an evolutionary biologist who
upgrades the toolkit
of evolutionary concepts so that we can
see
more clearly how organisms function and
why
and telomeres was a proof of concept
right that paper was a proof of concept
that the toolkit in question works
as for the need
to pursue it further i think it's kind
of absurd and you're not the first
person to say maybe that was the way to
go about it but the basic point is look
the work was good
the it turned out to be highly
predictive
frankly the model of senescence that i
presented is now widely accepted
and i don't feel any misgivings
at all about having spent a year on it
said my piece
and moved on to other things which
frankly i think are bigger
i think there's a lot of good to be done
and it would be it would be a waste to
get overly
narrowly focused there's so many ways
through this space of science and
the the most common ways to just publish
a lot let's publish a lot of papers do
these incremental work and
uh exploring the space kind of like ants
looking for food you see you're tossing
out a bunch of different ideas some of
them could be brilliant breakthrough
ideas
in nature some of the more confidence
kind of publications all those kinds of
things
did you consider that kind of
path and science of course i considered
that but i must say
the experience of having my first
encounter with the process of peer
review
be this story which was frankly a
debacle from one end to the other
with respect to the process of
publishing
it did not it was not a very good sales
pitch
for trying to make a difference through
publication and i would point out part
of what i ran into and i think frankly
part of what explains
carol's behavior is that in
some parts of science there is this
dynamic
where pis parasitize their underlings
and if you're very very good you rise to
the level where one day
instead of being parasitized you get to
parasitize others
now i find that scientifically
despicable
and it wasn't the culture of the lab i
grew up in at all my lab
in fact the pi dick alexander who's now
gone but who was an incredible
mind and a great human being he didn't
want his graduate students working on
the same topics he was on not because it
wouldn't have been
useful and exciting but because
in effect he did not want any confusion
about
who had done what because he was a great
mentor and the idea was actually
a great mentor is not stealing ideas and
you and
you don't want you don't want people
thinking that they are so
anyway my point would be um
i wasn't up for being parasitized
i don't like the idea that if you are
very good
you get parasitized until it's your turn
to parasitize others
that doesn't make sense to me um a
you know crossing over from evolution
into cellular biology may have exposed
me to that
that may have been par for the course
but it doesn't make it
acceptable and i would also point out
that my work
falls in the realm of synthesis
my work generally takes evidence
accumulated by others and places it
together
in order to generate hypotheses that
explain
sets of phenomena that are otherwise
intractable
and i am not sure that that is best
done with narrow publications that are
read by
few and in fact i would point to the
very conspicuous example of richard
dawkins
who i must say i've learned a tremendous
amount from and i greatly admire
dawkins has almost no publication record
in the sense of peer-reviewed papers in
journals what he's done instead
is done synthetic work and he's
published it in books which are not
peer-reviewed in the same sense and
frankly i think there's no doubting his
contribution
to the field so my sense is if richard
dawkins
can illustrate that one can make
contributions to the field without
uh using journals as the primary
mechanism for distributing what you've
come to understand
then it's obviously a valid mechanism
and it's a far better one from the point
of view of accomplishing what i want to
accomplish yeah it's really
interesting there is of course several
levels you can do the kind of synthesis
and that does require
a lot of both broad and deep thinking is
exceptionally valuable
you could also public i'm working on
something with andrew huberman now you
can also publish
synthesis sure that's like review papers
they're exceptionally valuable
uh for the communities it brings the
community together it tells the history
tells a story where the community has
been it paints a picture of where the
path
lays for the future i think it's really
valuable and richard dawkins is a good
example of somebody that does that in
book form
that he kind of walks the line really
interestingly
you have like somebody who like neil
degrasse tyson who's more like a science
communicator richard dawkins sometimes a
science communicator but he gets
he gets like close to the technical to
where it's a little bit
it's not shying away from being
really a contribution to science no he's
made he's made real contributions
um in book form yes yeah really it's
fascinating
i mean uh roger penrose i mean some
similar kind of
idea that's interesting that's
interesting synthesis does not
especially synthesis work
work that synthesizes ideas does not
necessarily need to be peer reviewed
it it it's peer reviewed
by peers reading it
well and reviewing it that's it it is
reviewed by peers which is not
synonymous with peer review and that's
the thing is people don't understand
that the two things aren't the same
right peer review is an anonymous
process that happens
before publication in a place where
there is a power dynamic
right i mean the joke of course is that
peer review is actually peer preview
right your biggest competitors get to
see your work before it sees the light
of day and decide whether or not
it gets published and you know again
when your formative experience with the
publication apparatus is the one i had
with the telomere paper
there's no way that that seems like the
right way to advance important ideas
yeah and you know what's the harm
in publishing them so that your peers
have to review them in public where they
actually
if they're gonna disagree with you they
actually have to take the risk of saying
i don't think this is right and here's
why right with their name on it
i'd much rather that it's not that i
don't want my work reviewed by peers but
i want it done
in the open you know for the same reason
you don't meet with dangerous people
in private you meet at the cafe i want
the work reviewed
out in public
you